all the heroes of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are gearing up for Avengers
endgame but one beloved character seems
to be m.i.a and it's not sitting well
with fans after a massive blast of 32
character posters for the upcoming
crossover event at the web fans
immediately took to social media with
one question where the heck is Korg in
case you missed it a bit of background
on the god of thunder was tossed into
the grandmasters dungeon on the planet
sakaar early on in 2017 saw Ragnarok at
core was the first to make his
acquaintance allow me to introduce
myself my name is caulk I'm kind of like
the leader in here made of rocks as you
can see but don't get that intimidate
chief he's huge blue and made of rocks
and although he has a most general
manner he's something of a budding
revolutionary later in the film Korg and
his companion meek joined Thor and his
team of Avengers in their bid to prevent
the destruction of Asgard
which doesn't go super well when Thor's
insanely formidable sister Halla the
goddess of death appears ready to wipe
out Asgard citizens the makeshift team
is forced to unleash the demon Surtur
who lays waste to the realm and kills
heller in the process as the Beast
embarks on his rampage Korg helpfully
provides commentary the damage is not
too bad as long as the foundations are
still strong we can rebuild this places
[Music]
now those foundations are gone sorry the
endgame posters trickled out over the
course of a day and as one sheets for
the Asgardian warrior Valkyrie and the
Fallen trickster god Loki dropped true
believers waited anxiously for Korg to
get his due but alas that never happened
should probably be mentioned that cord
was portrayed by Thor Ragnarok director
Taika Waititi who has been just a little
bit busy in addition to creating a small
screen adaptation of his 2014 comedy
feature what we do in the shadows for
effects ytt helmed and appeared in the
forthcoming drama d jojo roberts and has
been lending his vocal talent to several
episodes of the currently in production
Disney Plus series the mandalorian on
top of all this he's serving as a
producer on the feature werewolves as
well as Time Bandits a TV adaptation of
Terry Gilliam classic 1981 film which
recently received a pilot order from
Apple soon to debut streaming service
with all of this on his place ytt can
perhaps be forgiven for not lobbying too
hard to return as a big blue
revolutionary in the end game but that
didn't keep fans far and wide from
expressing their disappointment
compounding the omission is the fact
that the characters fate was left and
clear while he was present for the
fights of the Asgardians aboard the
Grand Master spaceship at ragnaroks
conclusion he was nowhere to be seen
during Avengers infinity Wars brutal
opening sequence aboard that very ship
in which Santos murders Heimdall snapped
Loki's neck and slaps a fully enraged
Hulk around like a rag doll this
oversight didn't sit well with fans many
of whom politely suggested that little
clarification was in order
there is a bright side to all this at
least Korg didn't get one of those
black-and-white dusted posters which is
more than we can say for Loki not to
mention to Charlie's little sister
Cherie
perhaps Korg actually defeats Santos and
ends game which at least one fan
suggested on Twitter we could almost get
on board with this although we're not
quite sure that trying to kill the mad
Titan with kindness is really the way to
go at any rates hopefully Marvel will
remember Korg as it brings closure to
the arts of a ridiculous number of
heroes in Avengers end game check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos about the MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]